hey guys how are you today I'm going to
be unboxing the new iPad pro which is
massive actually when I walked out of
the Apple Store my sister who doesn't
she was joking she's like I do I a
laptop because this box is huge I mean
this is the size of most Apple laptop
boxes Jena is there something over there
like that's like sharp cuz I can't buy
my knife guess what I just barely
touched this wrapping and I was able to
cut it with my fingernail so we're okay
here it is it's freaking big what this
is huge
I haven't even opened the box yet are
you ready for this oh my god it is
seriously so big oh my god what the heck
am I gonna do with this honestly this is
the size of like a television and it's
almost more expensive than a television
seriously my goodness look look at this
thing yeah it's
I don't even know what to say
it is it's massive
great Scot this is the size of my body
this is the size of my dog okay well
while that's turning on let's see what
else we have in the box we've got a nice
little brick which can never have enough
of these yeah well that's a little far
okay so this time around Apple did
something a little bit different usually
they have different models in the
cellular version but they only have one
model in the cellular version and that
is the 128 gig so it also come in the 32
which you can get in Wi-Fi and like most
of the Apple finishes you can get it in
the silver the Space Gray and the gold
sad it's not the rose gold though which
I probably wouldn't have got it in
anyway cuz it's a little crazy
are you talking to a size comparison of
the new iPad pro to a bunch of other
Apple products and let's see how they
all sort of shape up iPad pro in
comparison to the 15-inch MacBook there
we have it now we've got the oh it's
actually bigger then the 13-inch MacBook
that recently just came out then we have
the iPad air iPad Mini iPhone 6s plus
don't know why I got this in gold still
upset about it iPhone 6s regular which
is my sister's the original iPhone and
the Apple watch so here is how they all
stack up kind of incredible so let's
start this thing up oh it's saying hello
hello to you my friend touch ID okay
this is so big oh my god look at this
fingerprint I can't I am like beyond and
shocked at how big this thing is I
picked up one of the white silicone
cases to match the case that I have on
my other iPhone which is kind of crazy
as I just bought this one in the
previous version of the silicone cases
and an All Whites case and now they put
a dark gray Apple logo on it I don't
think it looks good at all when I open
up the packaging of this one I was like
what is this for what are you doing and
they did the same thing on this one too
it's not very Apple like it doesn't
match oh my god this is this is hard to
open oh it's actually not hard at all
all you do is pull this tab is so big
holy crap this is incredible it is
incredibly large here's the case here's
the iPhone gosh I do not like this dark
logo and it's fine it's just not very
Apple ish if they would have done it in
light gray I think it would have looked
a lot better it's too like hey hello
we're here oh my god like taking a
picture on this is insane oh my gosh
this is crazy
that's the new iPad pro I'm kind of
excited to get a chance to play with it
the smart Keyboard does not come for
another week or two and the pencil also
will be here I think in maybe like four
or five days so I'll be sure as soon as
I get that to do a little review and
show you guys how that works I'm kind of
excited for this because I think this is
a device that is not necessarily for
everyone this is going to be something
for people who might not decide to ever
get a laptop so this would probably
replace that also for artists and
illustrators and things like that it's
going to be great for because it does
work with a pencil and the pencil only
will work on the iPad pro they forced
touch
there's no forced touch man I almost
cracked my screen I put so hard on it
I'll see you guys next video this thing
is so big my goodness
to be able to control and find the
animals to snap their photos or you can
just swipe on the screen to move it
around but I prefer moving the phone
around like crazy because it's a lot
more fun and interactive